[музика]
кола і закінчиться вина ніхто там стрибає
до дому і вся наша сім'я синок у будди
разом і ми брали участь very
cool мовою мчати вина то я буду
проводять і більше години зі своїм або
гноми
[музика]
ви закинете вина я прибуду школи
забудусь і спокійно ти
голі за кімчі цивіна я йду гуляти з
друзями
кози кенджі цивіна я слухатиму супер
до шок низької жіночі друзями пару днів
ми спостерігали 1100 дітей мого
ви за кекс цілісна переносимо ногу ось
так ти стоїш тоді ти зі своїм і вантажем
словом виступив
57-а були акули
німці до поговоримо з казино
[музика]
у евіна таким же team я повільно у всіх
категорій у дружини посміюся то народитиму
ви закиньте тягою але ми розум крек лиму
ура
едему новий топ і я ти не ми сім'я ми
йому вийти
і
закінчиться вина улюблені у всіх своїх
ліпних
він закінчиться моя skype тариф на
довелося дротяним
він закінчиться вина наріжте тут німці
всі мою лили і наступати доводчиків
обсязі
[музика]
він
власне і тому що хоча
сам
дичину цивільно мусульмани сміття парасолька
медину до школи бугурти ви так за саму
ванну вже за вчителі ми і будемо чути
тисяч у розуму та їжі не
[музика]